[Musique]
en ce temps de lakovic 19 tous les
moyens sont bons pour se maintenir en
santé on peut être tenté aussi de
vouloir même renforcer notre système
immunitaire
sur les réseaux sociaux des publications
virale propose des solutions de toutes
sortes pour renforcer notre système
immunitaire
que ce soit avec des aliments ou encore
des suppléments fenaux et vitamine c est
même cocaïne ont fait la manchette
ici on suggère un mélange curcuma et de
miel
la du citron et de l'eau pour
s'immuniser contre le nouveau
coronavirus stéphanie côté
nutritionniste
chaque jour elle prend un moment pour
faire de l'exercice c'est dans sa cour
que nous la rencontrons pour aider
partir le vrai du faux au sujet du
système immunitaire qui on regarde bien
nos distances ce sera fait la seule
façon de se protéger contre la copie 19
c'est de maintenir une distance physique
et de se laver les mains
donc c'est ce qui prouve est ce qu'on
doit faire des consignes essentielles
selon les experts de la santé publique
mais partout sur la planète on trouve
selon les pays des recettes pour se
prémunir de la coved 19 mai oignons le
gingembre peuvent prévenir que ce soit
de consommer un thé à l'ail au venezuela
des bananes ou une herbe médicinale en
thaïlande
delahaye en tunisie une sorte de
champignons ou du thé comme ici au
canada
nos collègues de siby s'ils sont allés
en caméra cachée chez un acupuncteur qui
vendait un thé protecteur de lakovic 19
il ya énormément prétentions par exemple
booster le système immunitaire le
renforcer et se prémunir contre la coque
19 se protéger s'immuniser tout ça c'est
utopique de penser qu'on peut qu'on peut
faire ça avec des aliments ou encore
avec des suppléments
aucun aliment de manière spécifique qui
peut renforcer notre système immunitaire
ce serait complètement illusoire de
prétendre ça pourtant certains aliments
sont reconnus pour leurs différentes
propriétés parfois même anti
bactériennes comme par exemple lie mon
domaine de recherche principalement
justement les effets
de différentes molécules sur le système
immunitaire
nous rencontrons via skype le chercheur
yvan boutin ya bien des choses qui
fonctionnent bien une bille tronc d'un
laboratoire dans des éprouvettes pour
faire des démonstrations
quand on essaie de transposer ça à des
populations humaines puis voir si
l'incident sur des infections
habituellement on n'a jamais rien de
très significatif
y a pas vraiment d'études qui a deux
monteurs de tout d'eau puis des études
qui sur un long terme qu'ils ont
démontré qu'ils en efficacité de ces
différents types de molécules compris
live mais les mythes sont tellement fort
et important que l'organisation mondiale
de la santé a émis des mises en garde
contre ces solutions miracles à base
d'ail ou d'huile de sésame par exemple
sur son site internet santé canada a
aussi fait des avertissements en ce sens
on peut pas attribuer de super pouvoirs
à certains aliments dans des capsules
web quel produit stéphanie côté tentent
d'informer sa communauté facebook sur le
sujet même si beaucoup de nutriments qui
sont impliqués dans ces militaires à
moins d'avoir une carence et de devoir
pallier une carence prendre des
suppléments ça ne va rien régler les
suppléments de vitamine c ou de zinc ou
de tout ce qu'on peut entendre parler ce
nom ça jamais été prouvée comme quoi on
peut nous se protéger contre un rhume en
temps normal et encore moins contre la
copie de 19 présentement
[Musique]
le fonctionnement du système immunitaire
et complexe le microbiote intestinal
soit les bactéries dans nos intestins
fait partie de ce système et joue aussi
un rôle dans nos défenses le microbiote
c'est entre autres la première ligne de
défense immunitaire ou c'est parce que
des millions des millions de bactéries
qui sont là comme des petits soldats et
qui sont la première ligne de défense
s'il ya des agresseurs qui veulent
entrer plus haut le microbiote qui est
équilibrée variée avec plein de sortes
de bonnes bactéries mais ça aide
notre système immunitaire a fonctionné à
son meilleur alors on pourrait vouloir
consommer des suppléments de
probiotiques pour aider notre système il
faut faire attention cette pop il est
aux biotechs ont bon dos et puis c'est
différentes souches de propriétés qui
sont est ceci est différent c'est
d'effets bénéfiques puis dans le col
actuelle coved 19 comme on connaît peu
de choses sur la maladie
bien malin celui qui serait capable de
prédire que ça touche tout ces souches
probiotiques soit efficace contre contre
l'infection
on ne va pas ingéré des bonnes bactéries
on va gérer des aliments qui vont faire
le bonheur de nos bonnes bactéries
ce qu'on peut faire de mieux
présentement pour être notre meilleur
c'est manger des fruits des légumes tous
les jours des aliments végétaux comme
les légumineuses les noix les graines
les grès entier le tofu donc ces
éléments là au quotidien une
alimentation équilibrée et surtout
végétal est encore la clé présentement
on est dans une période où on est on est
à l'affût on veut des solutions pour se
protéger il ya des gens qui pour qui des
bénéfices à partager ses articles là où
à nous vendre des suppléments donc faut
faire attention dans toute cette dans
toute cette histoire
enfin attention parce que souvent les
gens vont utiliser chez études
préliminaires qui ont été faits dans les
conditions de laboratoire contrôlé ont
utilisé ça c'est bon pour quelque chose
c'est justement ce que ce soit aussi
bien partir d'internet industrie aussi
qu'ils aiment bien en faire déjà course
et puis c'est une question marketing de
promotion pour se le cacher alors si on
ne peut renforcer
pouvons-nous d'un autre côté affaiblir
notre système immunitaire
le stress en soi ce n'est pas bon pour
le système immunitaire et en plus on
embarque dans un cercle vicieux avec le
stress parce que quand on est stressé
souvent on dort moins bien le manque de
sommeil sont si ça affaiblit système
immunitaire donc ce sont deux facteurs
lucky et qui entrent en ligne de compte
et qu'on veut mettre toutes les chances
de notre côté ben oui on est mieux de
cette gérer notre stress de bien dormir
de bien manger également sortir on peut
prendre l'air con bouger je voudrais la
seule façon qu'on ne trouvait ce qu'on
appelle la vaccination
en attendant la découverte du vaccin
attention à tous ces remèdes miracles et
miser sur les bonnes habitudes de vie
selon stéphanie celi qu'il aime c'est le
gros bon sens ce sont les bonnes
habitudes de vie qui sont toujours
importants en temps normal mais encore
plus peut-être quand un virus qui
courent
[Musique]